my wife and i have built six
multi-eight-figure companies in the last
five years our current portfolio does
about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you my name's alex mozi
uh we run acquisition.com and i was
interviewed recently for a segment on a
two-hour long podcast and the segment
that i want to show you is a really cool
clip that we just talked about what it
was like to literally build these
companies together being married and the
balance between work life and marriage
all right so um like i said enjoy and
i'll see you guys on the other side i
mean a lot of people used to get on me
about like you need more work-life
balance like blah blah blah and it's
just like i just like you have one life
and they are your terms and no one
else's terms and we optimize typically
for the things that we enjoy doing and
like if you have more stimulus from
working than you do from not working
then like work and then if you feel like
at some point you have traded off
something that you don't want to trade
off for then you can adjust that's why
i've always felt i enjoy working like
what was it my mom so
we have like a wedding to go to on
the day after my birthday yeah so we
were talking about you know we have to
fly up on my birthday she's like oh we
could do this on your birthday this time
like no i just want to work she's like
no but it's your birthday you shouldn't
have to work and i was like i want to
work that's all i want to do i just want
to work even uh santa monica my birthday
i was like the only thing i want to do
today is work that was it
just wanted to work i mean everybody
wants to they're like man do something
do
do something you love and you'll never
work another day in your life but like
it's just because everyone has this
really poor definition of work but like
if if you have accomplished that which
obviously you have you're just living
yeah and like what you do in life so
i'll i'll rewind something really
quickly which is like 2021 i did nothing
i owned all the companies pounded out a
lot of cash flow and i did nothing and
it was a very miserable year for me
because i tried to spend the money that
i was making and i couldn't like it was
just not even really a possibility and
so like i got into a place of like why
why am i even doing this like what's the
point like i'll never even be able to
spend this money that i have like why
have i been doing all this stuff and in
starting acquisition.com or at least
making that the sole focus now again and
being able to build all the
infrastructure you know hire the teams
and all the stuff that we're doing on
that side of the business like i have so
much joy getting back into the game
because i feel like i've been kind of
like in a super high leverage position
for like an extended period of time that
i exited the business because i thought
that was what the next natural step was
supposed to be which is like you go from
ceo to owning it as shareholder or board
of directors whatever and that is very
much what happened but i realized that
for me at least it's like i work to
create options not to not work and so a
lot of people like they work really hard
to not have to work later it's like no
no it's like i work to have the option
to work and so i can choose to work and
that choice is the freedom that i have
and so like if i'm choosing with the
optionality that i have to work then
that is exactly what i want to do just
being on the other side of it of like
going to the like there's literally no
way i can spend this money for the rest
of my life mountaintop like the only
thing that i wanted to do was the thing
that got me here which is like i love
working and so it's the thing that i
find meaningful and i think that maybe
you shift direction in terms of like
maybe some of the stuff that you create
like maybe there's some things that you
create that are for youtube versus like
for gram and i just think that it just
slowly optimizes to only doing things
for gram which a lot of times still ends
up being that but like you get there
backwards it's like if you made it
purely for you then you might be able to
make a video after that that's like i
walked 300 miles and i didn't film
anything and this is what i learned like
that would probably be a really valuable
video because you probably would have
some interesting insights like i didn't
film either of the grant cardone videos
and then just made videos about the
calls of like my takeaways and they were
still really great videos interesting
okay so my only thought to that is like
you are in a very unique position
because you run this business with your
wife and and stuff like that and i think
that marriage plays a big part in my
life yeah and i think marriage is a
compromise and so my my wife doesn't
like it when i work as much and her i
guess her her like love language is what
quality time or whatever and i think
graham his girlfriend macy is similar
and i think that there's a compromise
there where yes graham if all he wants
to do is work that's great and he can
work and work and work but i think that
marriage a successful marriage is truly
a compromise and if if it turns out that
you know
like like you're really good i have like
so many thoughts right now yeah it's
stimulating conversation
and i think yeah and i think everybody's
in a unique position because you know
definitely like there's you you could
say well you know i'm gonna grind away
now so that you know i don't have to
work in the future and we could spend
time together or you can kind of balance
and live in the now and live in the
future but i think everybody's kind of
in a unique position but i think that
that part of your life is is is always
going to be a compromise to some sort of
extent so i think it's a belief that you
choose to define it that way yeah i'm
okay yeah i'm okay compromise is a
belief statement like that's not a
statement of fact that is a belief and
so like i don't believe that marriage is
compromised tell us your experience with
that because i have a because i'm sure
we all have different experiences
mine in the beginning was that i did
find that there was a compromise because
macy came from the mindset like you know
five or six pm comes around uh you're
done with work yeah and you're free and
my mind works 24 7. uh i tried that and
i woke up really early i'd wake up at
like 5 a.m so i could be done by 5 p.m
and the night and i that worked for
actually quite a while because i
actually found it was so productive in
those morning hours that i could be done
by five and be like oh wow this is great
but over a long time trying to figure
out like a balance i found myself i
wasn't myself like i i was really i felt
anxious i was just like uptight i was um
like about what part like no because
because i couldn't work during the hours
that i wanted to work like sometimes you
just have this there's days where it's
just like no no i'm so focused and i got
it like you have that concentration you
just have to continue
and so having that freedom for me if i
don't have that i just wasn't myself and
i was miserable yeah what i'm going to
say and i
i have very strong views um and they are
not common um but i also think that i
don't want to live a common life and so
that i cannot have common views so just
like as a as a big disclaimer to that
like i've only seen two dynamics that
work in relationships over like an
extended period of time one is kind of
the like we're in it together and the
other is like the you know cheerleader
and quarterback cheering you on but the
thing is is like i can tell i can speak
a lot to the you know we're in the game
together um for me i know personally
like i had two
very long relationships that were two
leader dynamics and to me i could not
imagine living life that way having now
lived what i live now because like
there's a certain amount of shared
respect that you never get with somebody
who does not know what it's like to be
in the battlefield or in the arena and
if i'm like i need to work for the next
three days and like write five book
chapters like there's not a discussion
it's like of course do your thing
there's no like there's no like i can't
believe you're like
into the flip side in the cheerleader
dynamic a cheerleader who's really
rooting for the team doesn't ask the
quarterback to come out when the game's
on the line and so i think that a lot of
people are running in what they consider
to be cheerleader dynamics but they are
inverted dynamics they're actually
sabotaging the game i think that it's
like in that dynamic it's harder in my
opinion to do the cheerleader
quarterback because you have to have a
very aligned mission and goals of like
the relationship it's easier to do that
in the dynamic that you're working
together because it's so clearly stated
with the mission the goals of like this
is where i want to go and this is how i
want to get there and like you want to
come with me and then you're very much
operating on this shared sense of
reality and it also becomes difficult
for entrepreneurs in my opinion now like
i mean i'm sure you've seen plenty of
people get divorces that they get older
and whatnot is that like if you're like
all right this will be interesting so
typically when people become attracted
so esther perel if you've heard of her
she's really interesting like
relationship person she's like one of
the top ted talks on it there's i think
it's called mating captivity is her book
but in the beginning you have kind of
this mystery because you don't know each
other and that's what creates like the
excitement right and as you get to know
each other over time you swing like from
uh mystery to familiarity right you get
a little bit more security get to know
each other better and it feels like more
and more amazing and so what you do is
you just keep trying to do that right
but when something happens that you over
correct and then you become siblings and
then it's like ah well that's not good
and so there it's not a problem to be
solved but a a dichotomy to be managed
right in terms of like how much space do
you create versus how much familiarity
what happens when people like
entrepreneurs specifically like have
their business and they
have the wife they spend more time in
the beginning and all of a sudden they
don't spend as much time together and
then they grow apart because they're
also
exposed to different stimuli right and
so you adapt to the stimuli that you
have then you grow apart on the flip
side if you're in my scenario where
we're like doing the same thing together
the downside of this one these couples
make five times more money than any of
the other uh versions that i just said
but the uh you can become too familiar
and then you just become siblings so for
us we actually create more space so it's
like we try to work on separate sides of
the house we don't attend the same
meetings so like at the end of the day
we can sit down at dinner like how was
your day and you can tell me something
rather than me saying like oh i was
there i know right yeah and so the
happiest couples are actually couples
that have
both have careers that are not
necessarily together so on average these
couples are the ones that because they
have a shared goal in terms of this is
what we want to do they've shared values
in terms of how they want to get there
and they respect one another and they
respect each other's goals and then they
walk kind of in parallel so you've got
the like i'm working the entrepreneur
and you've got the stay-at-home wife
there's many times everyone's seen that
one go wrong there's the like we're both
working together in it where you so
these people have to uh correct for
trying to create more familiarity these
ones have to create more space so you
have the space to be missed and then
these ones tend to be in the middle
already and so they just kind of like
have to keep walking and so for me it
was actually just interesting seeing the
the different dynamics um and like how
we had to correct in the beginning like
we were wait we spent all day every day
together and the business was small so
it was like she was there and i was here
and we worked out together and we ate
together and we did that for like two
years and i was like you know maybe i'll
sit on different meetings than you yeah
but like seeing the level of like
commitment and loyalty that you get from
that and i don't know so i want a little
bit of a tangent there but i i have
strong beliefs around around that and i
think that you don't have to compromise
anything if you don't want to